هذا وقالت قياده العمليات الاخرانيه في
الجبهه الشرقيه ان القوات الروسيه اطلقت
عشرات الصواريخ ونفذت نحو عشرين غاره
استهدفت فيها مناطق تحت سيطره القوات
الاخرانيه في اقليم دومباس منها كوره خوفك
او عفوا كره خوفقا وكرامه تروسك واضافت
قياده العمليات ان القوات الروسيه تحاول
ان تعزز مواقع ها في محاور باخبط ولمان
وافديفكا حيث استهدفت مباني سكريه واشارت
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفتني قطر تجمع
للقوه الروسيه ومعسكرات للتعبئه ومستودعات
للذخيره بمناطق في لوغاز وفي الجبهه
الجنوبيه
اما هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه فا افادت ان
نحو 260 جنديا روسيا قتلوا او جرحو في
مناطق ميليتوبيل وتوكماك وبريديانسك في
مقاطعه جنوبيه البلاد وقالت ان قصف قواتها
لتلك المناطق في اليوم الثاني من العام
الجديد اسفر عن تدمير 10 وحدات من المعدات
العسكريه ومستودعين للذخيره ونقاط انتشار
اخرى للقوه الروسيه
13 غاره على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
وموقع اخر لانظمتهم الصاروخيه اضافه الى
تدمير نقطتين تحكم ونقطه مراقبه للمسيرات
العسكريه الاخرى
مدنيين اثنين واصابه خمسه جر قصف الروسي
استهدف المدينه وقال ان الروس قصفوا عموم
اراضي المقاطعه الجنوبيه خلال اليوم
الثاني 73 مره مستخدمين المدفعيه وقذائف
الهاون واضافت ان القصف استهدف ايضا حوض
بناء السفن وخط انابيب الغاز ومباني خاصه
وسكنيه
عمر الحاج ومن موسكو مراسلتنا رانيا
الدريدي اذا عمر ورانيا اهلا بكما في هذا
اليوم طبعا واضح ان التصعيد على الجبهتين
مستمر والخسائر ايضا
يتكبدها الطرفان ابدا معك عمر الحاج حدثنا
عن اخر التطورات السياسيه وميدانيا
نعم ليله كما ذكرت بالفعل كلا ااا الجانب
كلا الجانبين الان يرد على الهجمات التي
ينفذها الجانب الاخر واقبل
ويستهدف كما يقول جانب الاوكراني على
الاقل نقاط التعبئه وايضا مستودعات
الذخيره ويحقق اصابات مركزه في هذه
المناطق باستخدام المنظمات الصواريخ
المتطوره وتحديدا الهايمرز التي تملكها
القوات الاوكرانيه القوات الاوكرانيه في
حديثها اليوم في بيانها اليوم تحدثت عن
الحق اضرار كبيره
منطقه
تحديدا في منطقه في مقاطعه لوهاسك وقالت
انها همم
صدت هذه المناطق قصه هذه النقاط
واستهدفتها بهذه الصواريخ واوقعت اصابات
مباشره ايضا انها تمكنت من صدها روسيه على
محاور ضخمه وايضا همم في النحاس وكذلك
الامر همم في
في اقليم في مقاطعه دنيا سمير القوات
الاوكرانيه ومنذ فتره تقول ان القوات
الروسيه عمدت الى تقليل قواتها او تقليل
زخم الهجمات في محور باخ من بالتحديد وهذا
ما اكسب هذه المنطقه هدوء النسبيه مقارنه
مع الاسابيع الماضيه على العكس مما يحدث
في مدينه في مقاطعه لوهاسك في الشمال لان
القوات الاوكرانيه
تتحدث عن اقترابها اكثر فاكثر من حصاري
والسيطره على مدينه كريمينا بعد ان اصرحت
يوم امس انها تمكنت من قطع الطريق الواصل
بين مدينتي كريمينا واسفه توبا ار 66
والممت على عشرات الكيلو مترات وقالت ان
انها سيطره ناريا عليه وان قوات روسيه لا
تستطيع ارسال تعزيزات او قوافل العسكريه
عبر ذلك المحور بل ان بعض وحداتها وصلت
فعليا الى هذا المكان وقطعته في بعض مناطق
الشماليه ايضا في همم في مقاطعه زكريا
القوات الاخرانيه قالت انها شنتها هجمات
باستخدام هذه الص على مواقع للقوات
الروسيه تحديدا في بريديانس وايضا في
تركماك التي تعد نقطه التجمع المهمه
للقوات الروسيه اا في وميلوتبول في الجنوب
هذه الجبهه وان كانت منذ فتره هادئه
مقارنه مع مناطق الاخرى ولكنها عادت
لتصعيد بعد ان كان هناك حديث عن نيه لهجوم
اوكرانيا يشنوا لاول مره على الاقل في هذا
المحور باتجاه نحو مواقع الجيش الروسي
ولكن حتى الان الامر يقتصر على القصف
واستهداف المناطق ومستودعات همم الذخيره
في هذه المقاطع كذلك الامر قالت القوات
الاوكرانيه ان هناك من جانب الاخر صواريخ
سقطت على من طراز همم 300 كذلك الامر في
مقاطعه دونيس وتحديدا في كره
كيف المناطق التي تعرضت قبل يومين الى قصف
عنيف من قبل القوات الروسيه عقب الاعلان
عن مقتل عشرات الجنود الروس من من جانب
الروسي في مدينه مكيفكوكانت القوات
الاوكرانيه قد تحدثت عن هذا الهجوم بعد
يومين فقط دون ان تحدد ارقام القتل على
الاقل من جهه نظر من جهه نظري الروايه
الاوكانيه في حين تتحدث مصادر عن مئات من
القتل عروس سقطوا في ذلك الهجوم